[Musik]
liebe besucherpolitik Zuschauer die Lage
zwischen China und Taiwan sieht
allmählich brenzlig aus diesen Sommer
genügte der Besuch nennt sie pelosis der
Sprecherin des US Repräsentantenhauses
und schon drehte die chinesische
Regierung durch eine riesige
Militärübung liegt an und China
umzingelte die Insel mit hunderten von
Schiffen und Flugzeugen seither liegen
die Nerven dies und jenseits des Pazifik
blank ähnliche Übungen gab es schon in
der Vergangenheit aber keinen davon
hatte so gigantische Ausmaße wie diese
letzte das chinesische Militär hat sogar
ballistische Raketen vor der Küste
Taiwans abgefeuert und zum ersten Mal
sind vier davon auch über die Insel
geflogen tja da fragt man sich natürlich
was denn die Hyper nervösen KP Bosse in
Peking in einer wirklichen Krise
abziehen werden wenn sie schon derart
krass die Kanone donnern lassen nur
wegen eines Kurzbesuchs einer
82-jährigen Dame deren mutigste
politische Tat darin bestand
demonstrativ ein Rede Manuskript Donald
Trumps zu zerreißen ach ja und dann
schlug sie auch mal Wellen weil sie sich
während des corona-lockdowns mal die
Haare frisieren ließ ihr seht schon ist
eine echte Rebellin eine ein Frau Armee
vor der ein Milliardenvolk wie die
Chinesen sicher zittern muss tja genutzt
hat den Chinesen das ganze säbelrassel
in das nichts los sie kam zog ihre
Visite durch und flog wieder nach Hause
und auch wenn derartige Provokation
nicht ganz neu sind erreichte diese doch
wieder eine ganz neue Eskalationsstufe
[Musik]
es ist klar dass ich in letzter Zeit die
Lage noch mal verschärft so sind zum
Beispiel Übergriffe der chinesischen
Luftwaffe Aufteilung
luftverteidigungszone mittlerweile an
der Tagesordnung Bomber Kampfjets
überwachungsflugzeuge Hubschrauber alles
kommt ständig durch und zwingt die
taiwanesischen Streitkräfte dazu in
konstanter Alarmbereitschaft zu sein die
Taiwan Frage ist nicht mehr nur ein
bloßes kurzlebiges Modethema sondern ein
zentraler Schauplatz wenn ich sogar der
Zentrale Schauplatz im strategischen
Wettbewerb zwischen den USA und China
aus asien-experte und Mitglied des
Nationalen Sicherheitsrats der Barmer
Regierung
da die USA und externe Kräfte
einschließlich der taiwanesischen
unabhängigkeitskräfte ständige
Provokation vornehmen werden die Übungen
intensiver und häufiger werden und sich
zeitlich und vom Umfang her ausweiten
Song ping militäranlöst und ehemalige
offizielle chinesischen Armee die
heftige Reaktion auf den Besuch pelosis
war nur das Symptom eines sich seit
einiger Zeit immer weiter verschärfenen
Prozesses die taiwanfrage hat aus
verschiedenen Gründen in den letzten
Jahren auf der internationalen Agenda
immer mehr an Bedeutung gewonnen
insbesondere auf der Agenda der
chinesischen Regierung
Politik haben wir schon ein paar Videos
von diesem Thema gebracht wir haben zum
Beispiel darüber gesprochen wie Teil
waren sich verteidigen und was ist von
der Ukraine lernen könnte so wie über
die Gründe für die chinesischen Anspruch
auf die Insel und über viele ähnliche
Fragen und dennoch lieben bisher viele
wichtige Fragen offen warum hat sich das
Interesse an Taiwan in letzter Zeit noch
mal gesteigert warum ist die
regierungschefins nach dem Besuch von
Lucy so ausgerastet was wird nun der
nächste Schritt Peking sein welche
Risiken drohen Teil waren wirklich in
naher Zukunft um heute all diese Fragen
zu beantworten haben wir für euch unter
fünf Aspekten die wichtigsten Gründe
zusammengefasst warum genau China
zunehmend von Taiwan ja geradezu
besessen ist und ich verspreche euch wir
holen hier zu einem richtigen
grundumschlag aus von Militär über
Politik hinzu Wirtschaft am Ende dieses
Videos werdet ihr hoffentlich den vollen
Durchblick haben was bei diesen
verworrenden und scheinbar bloß schon
chauvinistischen treiben wahrlich nicht
so einfach ist bevor wir loslegen würden
wir euch aber noch gerne den Durchblick
beim ebenfalls überaus wichtigen Thema
Passwortsicherheit verschaffen also hier
kommt unser heutiger Sponsor Nord worum
es bei nordpass geht nun hast du einen
Überblick darüber wie viele
Benutzernamen und Passwörter du in
letzter Zeit erstellt hast Website
Anwendungen Emails ich wette dass du
mittlerweile eine riesige Menge
anpasswort dann für all diese Dienste
angehäuft hast oder aber du hast die
kardinalsünde begangen und das Silbe
Passwort mehr als einmal benutzt komm
schon ich wette das hast du auch schon
mal getan es ist normal dass wir
aufgrund von Zeitdruck oder schierer
Faulheit zu einfacher Passwörter
verwenden oder diese gar nicht recycelt
und jetzt kommt die unbequem aber leider
umso folgenreichere Wahrheit in der
heutigen Zeit können wir uns eine solche
Nachlässigkeit immer weniger leisten und
zwar keiner von uns in wir dürfen unsere
Privatsphäre und unsere private
Sicherheit nicht so einfach auf Spiel
setzen aber jetzt kommt die gute
Nachricht mit nordpass kannst du
automatisch sichere Passwörter für jedes
deine Konten erstellen und sie haben
einen Ort speichern ohne dass du sie dir
merken musst und nicht nur das mit
diesen Schnitten Passwort Manager kannst
du auch die Daten deiner Bank und
Kreditkarten ganz einfach speichern und
abrufen so dass du beim Online bezahlen
Zeit sparst und die Kartendaten bei den
Shops selbst Speich okay klingt ganz
nett nicht wahr nordpass geht jedoch
noch einen Schritt weiter und schützt
deine Daten nicht nur passiv sondern
proaktiv mit einem ganzen Arsenal von
security features Nord fast premiums
kennt zum Beispiel ist Internet
kontinuierlich nach deinen Daten aber
findet heraus ob diese nicht
möglicherweise gelegt wurden und falls
dies der Fall sein sollte wann ist die
ich so dass Du rechtzeitig reagieren die
Gefahr bannen kannst bevor schlimmeres
Unglück hereinbricht und das Beste für
die visualpolitik Community hat nordpass
eine ganz besondere Aktion in petto
ganze 4 Monate kostenlose Nutzung plus
eine Sonderangebot über das du alles
erfährst wenn du den Link
nordpass.com/visualpolitik aufrufst den
ich dir in die Beschreibung unter diesem
Video packe natürlich kannst du alles in
Ruhe unverbindlich und völlig ohne
Risiko ausprobieren im nordpass kommt
mit einer 30-tägigen Geld zurück
Garantie was sie sich bis dahin nicht
von seinen Vorzügen überzeugen sollte
also klick auf den Link probieren
nordpass aus und erhöhe deine private
Sicherheit du hilfst damit natürlich
auch uns finanziell und das geht auch
mit einer Spende unabhängig von nordpass
den Link dazu findet ihr ebenfalls in
der Beschreibung unter dem Video so und
jetzt schnell nach Südostasien wo wir
die Besessenheit Pekings mit Taiwan und
die Gründe dafür endlich richtig unter
die Lupe nehmen werden
[Musik]
Probleme mit Entscheider
die Integration Taiwans zählt seit jeher
zum Programm der sogenannten
Kommunistischen Partei China ist denn
schon als sie in Peking die Macht
übernahm war Taiwan aus ihrer Sicht eine
abtrünnige Provinz auf der sich die
reaktionären Kräfte unter changaischek
hartnäckig hielten dass die heutige
Regierung unterschiedlichen fing nun
aber den Ton gegenüber Taiwan nochmal
deutlich verschärft hat geht über den
alten Anspruch hinaus und ist dabei doch
auch keineswegs zufällig den ersten
wichtigen Grund hierfür findet man bei
shamping selbst
es ist die alte Leier ein langjähriger
Anführer will seine angestammte macht
noch ein bisschen länger behalten als
dies gesund wäre auf dem Höhepunkt
aussteigen und die Macht einem
Nachfolger übergeben das ist weder
putinsding noch schießt und den Stall
bedeutet es dass er mit der vom weißen
denkstoff pink eingeführten Regel der
Machtübergabe nach zwei Amtszeiten
berichten und verändert 2022 eine dritte
Amtszeit anstreckt wie gesagt muss ich
der chinesische Staatschef dazu aber
über die bisher üblichen
amtszeitbeschränkungen der
Kommunistischen Partei Chinas
hinwegsetzen etwas was seit mauszeiten
nicht mehr passiert ist wie man sich
denken kann stößt schieß anlegen bei den
Parteikadern allein schon aus diesem
Grund nur bedingt auf Begeisterung
zwischen pink ist also zur Zeit Fieber
hat damit beschäftigt seine Rückhalt und
seine Legitimität zu stärken und was
gebe es dafür besseres als sich einen
äußeren Feind zu finden und sich ein
Stück Land auszusuchen dass es heim ins
Reich der Mitte zu holen Geld zumal ist
die perfekte Gelegenheit ist sich als
starker Führer zu präsentieren der China
wieder zu alter zu verhelfen wird in
diesem Fall der Führer der bereits
Hongkong endgültig unter die totale
Kontrolle Pekings gebracht hat und bald
das gleiche mit Taiwan tun wird aber das
ist nur das erste Ziel des eskalierenden
Nationalismus der chinesischen Regierung
der zweite Grund liegt darin die
Aufmerksamkeit von etwas abzulenken
worüber wir hier official Politik schon
vor kurzem berichtet haben aber schon
bald wieder berichten werden die
gigantische Wirtschaftskrise auf die
China zusteuert
[Musik]
selbst die in Zahlen Kosmetik erfahrener
KP kann es nicht mehr leugnen die
chinesische Wirtschaft hat wahrlich
schon bessere Zeiten gesehen mit
Ausnahme der corona-phase ist die
aktuelles Wachstum das niedrigste seit
30 Jahren die Jugendarbeitslosigkeit
nimm stetig zu und das Land steht am
Rande einer großen Wirtschafts- und
vielleicht auch Finanzkrise mit anderen
Worten und den droht der chinesische
wohlstandsmotor abgewürgt zu werden und
damit breche auch der stillschweigende
Pakt zwischen der Kommunistischen Partei
und der chinesischen Gesellschaft denn
dieser lautete bislang die Untertanen
stellen die Regierung oder die
Kommunistische Partei nicht in Frage und
im Gegenzug garantieren euch die hohen
Tiere in Peking einen gewissen Wohlstand
und eine schnell wachsenden
Lebensstandard aber die Frage ist was
macht jeder gute Politiker wenn er bei
einem wichtigen Ziel versagt genau er
zaubert ein anderes aus dem Hut
wenn es der chinesischen Wirtschaft
einmal schlecht geht ist es für
Politiker ein probates Mittel mit neuen
gerne besonders drastischen Forderungen
aufzuwarten in diesem Fall mit einer
vielen nationalistischeren Agenda zu der
auch die Forcierung der taiwanfrage
gehört für die chinesische Regierung
scheinen so Wachstum und Wohlstand
plötzlich nicht mehr an erster Stelle zu
stehen was jetzt vor allem ziel ist die
Wiederherstellung der größte der alten
und glorreichen chinesischen Nationen
das was bringt die große nationale
Verjüngung nennt ja ob da vielleicht
jemandem weiß gemacht werden soll man
können mit einer ominösen nationalen
Verjüngung irgendwie die rapide
demografische Alterung Chinas aufhalten
naja wenn es mal schief läuft oder man
sonst nichts mehr hat wickelt man sich
eben gern in eine Fahne und schief läuft
in der chinesischen Wirtschaft zur Zeit
zu einiges da ist die auf das Land zu
rollende demografische Krise oder Anfang
präsenter ist aktuell eine
Immobilienkrise wie sie das Land bisher
noch nicht gesehen hatte in China hat er
sich über viele Jahre eine
Immobilienblase gebildet diese begann zu
platzen als evergrand einer der größten
chinesischen immobilienkonzerne
zusammenbrach Zusammenbruch wurde
zumindest in der Öffentlichkeit etwa ab
September 2021 bekannt jetzt schaut euch
an was darauf sagt 11 Oktober 2021
skisamping sagt dass die
Wiedervereinigung mit Taiwan für Chinas
Verjüngung unabdingbar ist wie ihr seht
spielen politische Erwägungen als eine
zentrale Rolle bei der Erklärung der
besonders scharfen Reaktionen aus Peking
in letzter Zeit aber ich hatte euch ja
noch mehr versprochen und siehe da es
lassen sich neben diesem Beispiel auch
entscheidende militärische
wirtschaftliche und diplomatische Motive
für Chinas Verhalten gegenüber Taiwan
finden der dritte Grund warum Taiwan
plötzlich so viel zwanghaftes Interesse
in Peking weckt liegt in der
Modernisierung der taimanesischen
Streitkräfte
in den letzten Jahren hat sich das
chinesische Militär modernisiert und
seine Fähigkeiten erweitert sein Ziel
ist es nun sein Einfluss weiter auf den
Pazifik auszuweiten nach dieser
Denkweise ist Taiwan der Schlüssel vor
allem für den Zugang zum Südchinesischen
Meer aber auch zum Pazifischen Ozean
insgesamt es handelt sich um zwei
notwendige Ziele für die
Funktionsfähigkeit der chinesischen
Marine denn wir auf dieser Karte seht
ist die Insel vor Moser also die
Hauptinsel Taiwans das wichtigste Glied
in einer Kette von Inseln welche die
chinesische Marine bei Bedarf blockieren
könnte und das ist bei Leibe noch nicht
alles wenn Taiwan und der chinesische
Herrschaft Stunde könnte China nicht nur
seinen Einfluss in der Region leichter
ausbauen sondern würde auch die
Kontrolle über einen der wichtigsten
Handelsrouten der Welt erlernen
die Taiwanstraße ist einer der
meistbefahrenen Schifffahrtsstraßen der
Welt was sie hält alle Containerschiffe
darunter 88% der größten Klassen
passieren sie es geht hier also um die
Hauptroute für Schiffe die Waren aus
China Japan und Südkorea in den Westen
transportieren und auch um die
Hauptroute über die diese Länder mit
Energie versorgt werden mit anderen
Worten Chinas gegen Südkorea oder Japan
während auf Peking angewiesen um einen
großen Teil ihrer exporter abzuwickeln
und sich mit Gas und Ölversorgung zu
können außerdem könnte Taiwan derzeit
von den Vereinigten Staaten als eine Art
Flugzeugträger und Versorgungszentrum
genutzt werden wenn im Gegenteil waren
wieder unter die Kontrolle Pickings käme
würde dieses Risiko vollständig
verschwinden so gesehen scheint der
chinesische Druck eine logische
Konsequenz der wachsenden militärischen
Präsenz des alten reichste Mitte zu sein
aber liebe visualpolitik Zuschauer wir
sind noch nicht fertig nicht bereits
sagte gibt es noch zwei weitere klare
Motive ein wirtschaftliches und ein
diplomatisches
[Musik]
chipblockade und Stresstest
die sogenannte Volksrepublik China
bereitet ihre Streitkräfte schon seit
Jahren auf eine Invasion Taiwans vor sie
hat zum Beispiel die größte Marine der
Welt aufgebaut gemessen an der Zahl der
Schiffe und nicht nur das auch die
sogenannte Volksbefreiungsarmee des
chinesischen Festlandes verstärkt ihre
präsenzer rund um Taiwan der erste
Schritt eine möglichen Konflikt könnte
jedoch ganz anders aussehen als eine
konventionelle Invasion in mehreren
früheren Videos hier auf visualpolitik
haben wir gezeigt wie sich Taiwan auf
eine Invasion vorbereitet damit diese
unverhältnismäßig viel kosten würde und
die russische Erfahrung in der Ukraine
dürfte nun auch nicht eben einen
anreißendes Beispiel für China sein eine
direkte Invasion zu stark deshalb hat
das pseudokommunistische Regime nun eine
andere Strategie ausprobiert eine see-
und luftblockade der Insel Formosa und
ihre 23 Millionen Einwohner indem man
die Insel aus hungert könnte Peking
vielleicht der an Zugeständnisse Auszeit
P gelangen dabei spielt ein Faktor der
Chinesen übrigens besonders in die Hände
seht euch mal diese Karte an der
Großteil der Wirkung der Industrie und
der Hefen Taiwans konzentriert sich
genau an der Westflanke der Insel also
direkt vor der Küste des chinesischen
Festlands auf diese Weise könnte picking
mit seinem Kriegsschiffen und U-Booten
leicht verhindern das Handelsschiffe die
Insel Anfahren oder verlassen und damit
im übrigen auch eine der
verkehrsreichsten Handelsrouten der Welt
abriegeln ebenso könnte die enorme
zahlenmäßige Überlegenheit der
chinesischen Luftwaffe in Verbindung mit
ihren neuen Flugzeugträgern ist
ermöglichen den Luftraum übertreibern
innerhalb kürzester Zeit dicht zu machen
und etwas ganz ähnliches könnte man auch
in großen Umfang mit dem Cyberspace
machen wie genau nun erschreckend
einfach indem man die Unterseekabel
kappt oder deaktiviert die rund 90% der
Daten transportieren welche die Insel
mit dem Rest der Welt austauscht
so ein Blockade würde wohl schnell
Verhandlungen erzwingen oder Tag P
wenigstens davon abhalten Entscheidungen
zu treffen die Peking nicht gefallen
zudem hätte sie den Vorteil dass sie
eine weniger eindeutige Aggression
darstellte wohin gegen die direkte
Invasion wahrscheinlich sofort die
verschiedenen Garantieversprechen der
Verbündeten Taiwans auslösen würde allen
voran die der USA indem man aber nur
eine Blockade vollzieht könnte man Zeit
finden und hätte eine bessere
Verhandlungsposition bei diplomatischen
Gesprächen während denen man zu mal
Taiwan noch ganz allmählich die Luft
Abdrücken würde letzteres ist umso
entscheidender Datei war den hohen Maße
von Brennstoff und Lebensmittel Importen
sowie von seinen Exporten abhängig ist
es ist also möglich dass die Insel einer
solchen Blockade nicht lange standhalten
könnte zumindest nicht ohne große
Verluste zu erleiden und das ist noch
nicht alles denn ihr wisst alle womit
die taiwanesische Industrien den letzten
Jahrzehnten die Weltmärkte erobert und
von sich abhängig gemacht hat nicht wahr
3 2 1 ganz genau taiwan hat sich zu
einem mikrochipmecker entwickelt
[Musik]
die kleinen integrierten Schaltkreise
sind zu unverzichtbaren Bestandteilen
der globalen technologischen Entwicklung
geworden von der Nanotechnologie bis zur
Robotik vom F35 bis zur Waschmaschine
nicht zuletzt auch den Smartphones die
wir alle in unseren Taschen tragen alle
modernen Geräte und Gadgets brauchen
diese kleinen Bauteile und strategisch
besonders bedeutsam in gewisser Weise
ist der technologische Wettlauf auch im
militärischen Bereich zu einem Wettlauf
um die besten Chips geworden gerade auf
diesem Gebiet hat sich Taiwan zum
weltweiten Marktführer entwickelt damit
ist die Insel heute ein wichtiger
Standort insbesondere für die
us-technologie und Militärindustrie eine
chinesische Blockade würde aber
natürlich die Lieferketten unterbrechen
und damit direkt zu einem Risiko für den
nationale Sicherheit von Andre Sam
werden
[Musik]
während ihres besucht traf sich eine
enzephalosi so auch mit der
Führungsspitze von TSMC im weltgrößten
Chip Hersteller während des Senator von
massachusett mit Unternehmensvertretern
über Investitionen und Möglichkeiten zu
Verb der Chip Lieferketten sprach das
war einer der wichtigsten Programmpunkte
des ganzen Besuchs und nicht nur das die
Regierungschefin Taiwans selbst die
übrigens zusammen mit von lobby-messe
lensky mit dem visualpolitik Wort 2021
als Politikerin des Jahres ausgezeichnet
wurde sieht in dieser internationalen
Abhängigkeit von Chips die beste
Garantie für das Überleben Taiwans denn
gerade im chip-bereich stößt der
chinesische Wille zu Aggression
gegenüber Taipan auf einem sehr hartes
reales Problem die chinesische Industrie
braucht nämlich auch jede Menge Chips
und natürlich nicht nur die Industrie
sondern alle das Militär Privathaushalte
nicht zuletzt der Staat wie soll er auch
sonst seinen ganzen Untertanen perfekt
überwachen können nicht wahr um euch die
Dimension der chinesischen Chip
Abhängigkeit deutlich zu machen
tatsächlich importierte asiatische Riese
mehr Chips als Öl allein im Jahr 2021
importierte China Chips im Wert von 430
Milliarden Dollar und 36 % davon kommen
aus Taiwan und da wäre es natürlich dumm
sich durch eine Blockade selbstzusankion
ach ja falls euch übrigens auch so
brennend interessiert wie die globale
Wirtschaft macht auf diesen Planeten
verteilt ist wer tatsächlich einen
wichtigen Schalthebel sitzt und ob dies
auch in Zukunft so sein wird habe ich
ein ausgezeichnete Nachricht für euch
wir von visualpolitik.de starten einen
neuen deutschsprachigen Kanal über
Wirtschaft er wird visual economic
heißen und in den kommenden Wochen an
den Start gehen wir drehen bereist die
ersten Videos schon jetzt haben wir aber
ein kleines Ratespiel für euch
vorbereitet was meint ihr welche Uniform
ich auf diesen neuen Kanal tragen werde
nein es wird sich nicht um Hawaii Hemden
handeln auch wenn die manchmal auch
auftreten und keine Angst es wird auch
ohne tägliches super spannend werden
aber schreibt uns doch einen Kommentar
auf welchen Dresscode in visual economic
ihr tippt ich bin schon richtig gespannt
so aber zurück nach Ostasien für die
Chinesen wäre es natürlich äußerst
attraktiv sich die teilbaresische
Produktion selbst unter den Nagel zu
erreichen womit das Rennen und Taiwan
auch zu einem Rennen um die modernsten
Chips geworden ist
einen weltmarktwirtschaft beherrscht
hatte ich dich logische und militärische
Vorherrschaft für die beiden großen
Supermächte geht es darum als
Supermächte zu überleben ihr seht also
eine chinesische Blockade der Insel vor
Mosa stellt ein echtes Risiko dar nicht
nur als Druckmittel gegen Taiwan selbst
sondern auch falls nötig gegen
Washington und den Rest der Welt
[Musik]
taktisch klug umgesetzt wäre sie eine
geeignete Vorstufe um die Insel dann
ganz in die Knie zu zwingen und zu
übernehmen damit haben wir also zwei
weitere Gründe für das drastisch
gestiegene Interesse an Taiwan gefunden
einerseits würde die Besetzung Teil
waren China erlauben eine der
wichtigsten Industrien und Technologien
der Welt zu übernehmen und damit alle
anderen von sich abhängig zu machen
andererseits könnte die Besetzung eine
Blockade oder sogar bloß die Androhung
einer Blockade China einen enormen
diplomatischen Vorteil verschaffen denn
so hätte man ein weiteres Druckmittel
gegen Taiwan selbst aber zugleich auch
gegen die USA und ihre Verbündeten in
der Hand so viel also zu den Gründen wie
Chinas schafft es Auftreten in der
taiwanfrage aber wir sind noch nicht
fertig
hinter der Fragen des Videos steht noch
aus welchem Szenario stehen wir
tatsächlich gegenüber werden wir
kurzfristig einen Invasionsversuch oder
auch nur eine längere Blockade erleben
wie könnte sich Taiwan davor schützen
aufgepasst
[Musik]
steht eine weitere Eskalation kurz bevor
nach allem was wir bisher gesagt haben
wird China so bald nicht von seinem
scharfen Kurs gegen Taiwan abrücken was
kann Taiwan also tun um Peking davon
abzuhalten seine Drohungen wirklich
wahrzumachen nun als erstes muss Taiwan
eine potenziellen Invasion eine
möglichst hohes Preisschild anheften es
darf sich für die chinesische Seite
schlicht und einfach nicht lohnen einen
Krieg zu beginnen das ist die sogenannte
Stachelschwein Strategie
in diesem Punkt kann Taiwan aktuell viel
von der Ukraine lernen und wir haben
darüber sogar ein eigenes Video gedreht
denn wenn uns die ukrainischen
Verteidiger gegen die russischen
Aggressoren Eis gezeigt haben dann dass
eine asymmetrische Kriegsführung mit
tragbaren Systemen wie javelyn Panzer
Abwehrraketen und Stinger
Flugabwehrraketen wenn Sie ein großer
Teil eingesetzt werden gegen selbst
besser ausgerüstete invasionsdrucken
ungeheuer effizient sein kann und vor
allem auch effektiv deshalb sagen immer
mehr Militärexperten das ist genau das
ist was Taiwan nun tun muss jede Menge
relativ günstige aber moderner Raketen
Drohnen hubschrauberabschluss am
Flugabwehrsysteme präzisionsartillerie
Minen dort pedos und so weiter
anzuschaffen im allgemeinen wäre eine
relativ preiswerte Ausrüstung nämlich
viel effektiver als teure U-Boote oder
Panzer sie müssen zudem bereit sein
einen großen Teil ihrer Bevölkerung an
diesen Infanteriewaffen auszubilden dies
könnte durch die Förderung von
wehrsportvereinen oder durch die Bildung
einer Art Landwehr erreicht werden vor
dem Erfahrungshintergrund in der Ukraine
und ähnlichen kriegen durfte China sich
also dreimal überlegen ob sich eine
Invasion wirklich lohnt sprich die
stachelschweinstrategie könnte aufgehen
das beseitigt allerdings natürlich
wieder das Risiko einer Blockade noch
die wirtschaftlichen Schaden den die
wachsenden Feindschaften in China und
die damit einhergehende Verunsicherung
anrichten könnte
[Musik]
um den entgegenzuwirken wird die
Stärkung der taiwanesischen
Partnerschaft mit seinen internationalen
Verbündeten sowohl wirtschaftlich als
auch militärisch zu einem wesentlichen
Aspekt genau aus diesem Grund hat Taiwan
auch bereits darum gebeten dem cptp
beizutreten und verhandelte den
Vereinigten Staaten noch über ein
gesondertes Freihandelsabkommen Taiwan
muss in jeder Hinsicht der beste
Verbündete der USA und deren Verbündeten
werden dennoch bleibt die beste
Nachricht für Taiwan vielleicht dass die
gefloppte Invasion Putins shishing Pins
Ehrgeiz zumindest für eine Weile
gebremst haben könnte die Ukraine hat
gezeigt dass die Dinge am Ende ganz
anders liegen können als auf der Krim
oder in Hongkong wo die internationale
Gemeinschaft kaum reagiert hat und die
Ukraine hat auch gezeigt wie schwierig
ist ein kann ein Land zu erobern ist ein
Einwohner ihre Unabhängigkeit um jeden
Preis zu verteidigen bereit sind und das
ist in Taiwan immer mehr der Fall
nachdem die junge Generation noch einmal
deutlich China kritischer eingestellt
ist als ihre Eltern das insgesamt ist
eine außerordentlich gute Nachricht für
die Unabhängigkeit Taiwans fassen wir
zusammen
[Musik]
alles in allem scheint es
unwahrscheinlich dass China in naher
Zukunft eine Invasion beabsichtigt eine
Blockade scheint da noch
wahrscheinlicher scheint aufgrund des
Drucks aus den USA und ihren Verbündeten
aber auch nicht unmittelbar
bevorzustehen US-Präsidenten hat nun
bereits das vierte Mal innerhalb eines
Jahres deutlich bekräftigt dass das
US-Militär Taiwan gegen ein chinesischen
Angriff auf jeden Fall verteidigen würde
seht euch an
beiden sagt die US-Streitkräfte würden
Taiwan im Falle einer chinesischen
Invasion verteidigen damit hat der
endgültig die langjährige amerikanische
Politik der strategischen Ambiguität
also Doppeldeutigkeit für beendet
erklärt
beides versprechen Taiwan zu verteidigen
stellt das Ende einer langjährigen
Leitlinie der US-Politik dar diese
politische Leitlinie stammt noch aus den
70er Jahren als die USA China als
Verbündeten gegen die Sowjetunion
gewinnen und daher nicht brüskieren
wollten sie zielte darauf ab beide
Seiten also sowohl China als auch Taiwan
in Schach zu halten in dem keine
wirklich wusste was die USA zwei tun
würden auf diese Weise konnte sich
einerseits Peking nie sicher sein wie
die Reaktion der USA ausfallen würde und
ob ein Angriff auf Tai war nicht zu
einem direkten Krieg mit den Amis führen
würde andererseits bedeutet diese
strategische Zweideutigkeit dass ich die
Taiwanesen auch nie ganz sicher sein
konnten wie weit die US-Hilfe überhaupt
gehen würde sie hatten also keine andere
Wahl als ihre eigene
Verteidigungsfähigkeit sicherzustellung
gleichzeitig peaking nicht zu sehr zum
provozieren wir haben über diese Politik
bereits in mehreren früheren Videos
gesprochen und ich werde sie euch alle
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
verlinken jetzt aber wo China der Feind
ist und nicht mehr als counterpart gegen
Moskau taucht hat beiden also endgültig
beschlossen ganz eindeutig zu werden und
sich klar auf die Seite Teil waren zu
stellen um Peking maximal von dummen
Schritten abzuschrecken auch beiden
Vizepräsidentin Harris fliegt es nach
Japan und Südkorea um die
verteidigungsachse gegen China und zum
Schutz der Taiwans nochmals zu stärken
auch über diese haben wir euch übrigens
schon in mehreren Videos ausführlich
informiert und wie immer sind sie unter
diesem Video verlinkt falls ihr sie noch
nicht gesehen habt Peking Strategie
müsste daher sich ausgeklügelter
daherkommen um erfolgreich zu sein
wahrscheinlich werden sie etwas
Ähnliches zu tun versuchen wie ein
Hongkong nämlich ihren wirtschaftlichen
Einfluss auf die Insel schleichend zu
vergrößern und gleichzeitig ihre
militärischen Kräfte aufzubauen parallel
genügt ist dann vielleicht schon die
Gefahr einer Blockade latent in der Luft
zu halten um mittelfristig Zugeständnis
zu Taiwans zu erreichen dies wäre aus
chinesischer Sicht wohl die beste Lösung
doch auch hier könnten die USA Ihnen
noch einen Strich durch die Rechnung
machen indem sie Teil waren nur
glaubwürdig genug den Rücken stärken
würden und das ist vielleicht der
Hauptgrund warum pink und seine
Regierung so verärgert darüber sind das
Teil waren sich wieder verstärkt den
besten annähernd wie es bei palusis
Besuchen und besonders sinnfällig
geworden ist umgekehrt könnte Chinas
immer radikaler werdende Rhetorik also
auch darauf abzielen Taiwans
Länderrisiko zu erhöhen welches
entscheidend für investitionsströme und
Kapitalkosten ist um so die
taiwanesischen Wirtschaft für die
Beziehung zum Westen zu bestrafen
zuletzt darf man allerdings auch zwei
Aspekte nicht vergessen die das
Kriegsrisiko erhöhen zum einen wird
China um die bedrohungskulisse aufrecht
zu erhalten auch weiterhin Übungen in
taiwanesischen Gewässern abhalten da
reicht dann unter Umständen schon eine
verirrte Rakete und aus der Übung wird
bitte ernster Krieg zum anderen zählt
die Integration Taiwans Fest zum
Programm der KP und ist auch fester
Bestandteil der persönlichen Agenda
Shisha banks in China dürften rationale
Mechanismen zwar noch deutlich häufiger
anzutreffen sein als in Russland doch
Putin hat bewiesen was ein alternativer
mit wenig Kontrolle von außen der sich
verbissen an seiner Macht und Ideologie
festklammert anrichten kann insofern
wird das zuletzt auch entscheidend sein
ob sie Integration Taiwans noch zu
seiner eigenen Biografie rechnen will
oder doch eher dynastisch denkt und
bereit ist eine mögliche Integration
kommenden Generation zu überlassen unter
Berücksichtigung all dessen ist also
sehr schwer zu sagen war es genau
passieren wird auch wir haben leider
keine Glaskugel sicher scheint jedoch
dass das chinesische Verhalten im Laufe
der Zeit eher aggressiver als
persönlicher werden wird mit Taiwanesen
also noch eine sehr ungemütliche Zeit
bevorsteht wir werden dieses global
strategisch extrem bedeutende Thema auf
jeden Fall weiter verfolgen dieses Video
war sozusagen erst für eine Einführung
um euch die notwendigen Grundlagen zu
vermitteln vergesst also bitte nicht das
Abo unbedingt mit Glöckchen um die
Fortsetzungen nicht zu verpassen aber
jetzt seid ihr erst mal an der Reihe
schreibt uns doch in den
Kommentarbereich welche Facetten des
chinesischen Expansionismus euch am
meisten interessieren wird es eine
Drohungen verstärken oder wird es
stattdessen versuchen die Spannungen zu
verringern um sich der Insel anzunähern
wird der kommende Parteitag der KP der
Wendepunkt sein an dem sich die Dinge
ändern und die wohl wichtigste Frage von
allen was sollte die internationale
Gemeinschaft tun sollte bei seinen
beiden nicht nur eine Garantie für
Taiwan Sicherheit im Kriegsfall abgeben
sondern darüber hinaus auch im Falle
einer Blockade die immer sind auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gibt es bitte ein Like falls mit euren
Freunden vergessen und keines unserer
Videos mehr zu verpassen testet bitte
auch unverbindliches Angebot unseres
heutigen Sponsors nordpass der für die
visualpolitik Community eine ganz
besondere Aktion bietet vier Monate
kostenlose Nutzung plus ein
Sonderangebot über das du alles erfährst
wenn über den Link
notpass.com/visualpolitik aufrufst den
ich euch in die Beschreibung unter
diesem Video packe natürlich freuen wir
uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende von
euch mit uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen PayPal Link dazu findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]